wieder ein Mann mit einem Messer mit
einer Machete wieder ein Somalia und
wieder eine Art Amoklauf diesmal zwei
tote das ist die Tat über die
Deutschland heute spricht passiert in
Ludwigshafen genauer in Oggersheim dem
Ort der durch Helmut Kohl so bekannt
wurde
zwei Menschen tot zwei schwer verletzt
messerdrama zur Mittagszeit in
Ludwigshafen mitten auf der Straße
bricht Streit aus ein 25-jähriger
Somalia Gerät an zwei deutsche plötzlich
geht der Somalia mit einer Stichwaffe
auf seine Kontrahenten los mehrere
Zeugen beschreiben die Waffe als Machete
also warum der Täter so agiert hat
welche Hintergründe Motiv aber noch
keine belastbaren Informationen aus der
laufen doch die Ermittlung dass die
Kriminalpolizei
Rückblick gegen Mittag mitten am
hellichten Tag mitten auf einer belebten
Straße muss der Täter auf seine Opfer
getroffen sein also kurz nach 12 Uhr
heute Mittag erreicht uns mehrere
Notrufe dass ein Täter mehrere Personen
mit einem Messer angegriffen hatte der
Täter ist dann von diesem ersten Tatort
mehrere hundert Meter weiter in einen
Drogeriemarkt geflüchtet vor dem
Supermarkt Gerät der Somalia an einen
weiteren Passanten er verletzt auch
diesen Mann schwer in diesem
Drogeriemarkt konnte der Täter durch
unsere sofort eingesetzten Polizeikräfte
gestellt werden die Kollegen mussten die
Schusswaffe einsetzen und der Täter
vorläufig festzunehmen schwer verletzt
wird der Mann in ein Krankenhaus
gebracht die Polizei bittet um Mithilfe
sucht nach eventuell gemachten
Videoaufnahmen von der Tat warnt aber
gleichzeitig deutlich wofür wir auf
jeden Fall abraten ist wenn Personen
handyfilme gemacht haben die frei in
sozialen Medien zu veröffentlichen
möglicherweise machen sich nämlich
komplett strafbar geben Sie die Filme
uns als Polizei damit wir die Tat
reduzieren können hintergründe und Motiv
der Wahnsinns Tat noch völlig unklar
und bei Bild live jetzt rein erwähnt
Chef der Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft
schönen guten Morgen Herr Wendt ja
Männer die mit dem Messern durch
Innenstädte ziehen und anscheinend ja
wahllos töten sind wir dem hilflos
ausgeliefert
und hilflos sind wir nicht man sieht ja
auch in diesem Einsatzfall das wenn
polizeiliche Einsatzkräfte schnell vor
Ort sind diese in der Lage sind auch
angemessen zu reagieren wenn im
Einzelfall ist notwendig ist auch von
der Schusswaffe gebraucht zu machen wird
auch dies in einem vernünftigen Rahmen
getan aber damit kann man halt nicht
immer rechnen die Polizei kann nicht
überall sein und deshalb ist erhöhte
Vorsicht geboten auch und vor allen
Dingen bei denjenigen Personen von denen
wir vorher wissen dass von ihnen eine
Gefahr ausgeht das kann man in diesem
Fall noch nicht bestätigen aber wir
wissen aus der Vergangenheit aus
ähnlichen Einsatzsituationen solche
Personen waren vorher bekannt sie waren
unter ärztlicher und therapeutischer
Betreuung und man wusste dass man ihn
eine zumindest abstrakte Gefahr ausgeht
und dann ist nach unserer Auffassung es
richtig und notwendig dass eine
intensive und sehr engmaschige Betreuung
stattfindet das können unsere Behörden
leider nicht immer gewährleisten
naja insofern schon hilflos ausgeliefert
weil ja eben in diesem Fall schon ihr
die Polizei eintraf das ging ja so
schnell schon getötet wurde schon
zweimal getötet wurde drei Männer
niedergemetzelt wurden haben Sie
irgendwelche Hinweise in diesem Fall
dass das ein Mann war ein Somalia war
der schon auffällig war bis dahin nein
diese Hinweise haben wir noch nicht die
Ermittlungen laufen ja und zwar in alle
Richtungen sie haben den Aufruf der
Polizei gehört das ist doch immer
hilfreich wenn Zeugen und Zeugen uns
ihre Aussagen ihre Beobachtungen aber
auch mögliche Videoaufnahmen und Fotos
zur Verfügung stellen das ist auch
notwendig um ein solches Geschehen
lückenlos zu rekonstruieren aber noch
einmal wir haben es jetzt auch wieder
einmal muss man sagen mit einem Menschen
aus einem ganz anderen Kulturkreis zu
tun und die Hilflosigkeit wenn ich sie
denn gibt der Opfer besteht auch und vor
allem darin dass man überhaupt nicht
damit rechnet das eine Person sich im
öffentlichen Raum aufhält
und mit anderen Machete bewaffnet ist
sowas kennen wir ja eigentlich nicht und
davon geht natürlich eine erhebliche
Gefahr aus zumindest dann auch wenn eine
Person möglicherweise und das scheint
hier ja der Fall zu sein psychisch
erheblich gestört ist unter die
Gewaltanwendung die Hemmung vor
Gewaltanwendung praktisch nicht mal an
ja leider kennen wir sowas ja von ganz
ähnlichen Taten aus der Vergangenheit
218 Offenburg ein Somalia junger Somalia
geht auf den Arzt los sticht den
niederer sticht ihn dann in Würzburg
2021 juni passierten Somalia junger
Somalia läuft durch die Innenstadt tötet
quasi wahllos drei Frauen getötet 9
weitere verletzt hier sehen Sie die
Szenen von damals noch mal das ging
minutenlang dort in der Würzburger
Innenstadt jetzt ist der Mann
schuldunfähig gesprochen worden wie
wichtig ist es in diesen Fällen klar zu
benennen die Herkunft auch dieser Täter
und mutmaßlichen Täter Somalia
und sicherlich kann man das nicht an
einer einzelnen Nationalität festmachen
das wäre fatal aber man muss schon
feststellen dass Menschen zu uns
gekommen sind die aufgrund
unterschiedlicher Erlebnisse
möglicherweise schwer traumatisiert sind
schwere psychische Störungen haben und
das müssen die Behörden im Blick
behalten und es sind die
Gesundheitsbehörden die das im Blick
behalten müssen nicht die
Polizeibehörden die Polizei ist in einer
solchen Situation dazu da Gefahren
abzuwehren und das tut sie auch im
Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten aber dieses
dann eine polizeiliche Einsatzsituation
keine therapeutische Situation und ich
habe die Befürchtung dass wir jetzt
wieder in den nächsten Tagen hören
werden ja wohl die Person war bekannt
auch dass sie psychisch gestört war war
bekannt auch das von ihr eine Gefahr
ausgeht war bekannt das haben wir leider
immer wieder gehört und was wir
möglicherweise auch in den nächsten
Tagen erleben werden den Norma kluge
Professoren die uns jetzt erklären dass
die Polizei nicht von ihrer Schusswaffe
Gebrauch gemacht werden dürfen weil sie
möglicherweise erst einmal für
Verständnis hätte werden müssen das
alles kennen wir aus der Vergangenheit
und es hat uns noch nie richtig
weitergeholfen danke an den
Polizeigewerkschaft Chef Rainer Wendt
heute früh bei Bild live danke
[Musik]